hey guys Pete max here Capcom was kind
enough to let us show you 10 minutes of
the new Strider remake so we're just
gonna save time and jump right in max
let's do this thing
all right let's hop right in yeah yeah
you know it's what I do so Peter I have
a terrible confession to make a very
dark secret in my past I've not played
any of the older Strider games but I'm
loving I thought you just a new one did
you just say you haven't played any of
the older stuff I'm saying that I'm a
disappointment to you and you should be
ashamed in so many words but tell me um
you played a little bit of this yeah
I've just played the new one like so for
instance here we're starting very
cinematic Strider for whatever reason he
lives in the future but he's still using
that uses a hang-glider
is this like a classic omage 2 Strider
history that I'm just completely missing
yeah I mean there's so many references
in this little demo everything from the
designer to character although that's
sort of reminiscent of the the redone
Strider that was represented in visual
Marvel vs. Capcom ok yeah so basically
the story here is there's a guy and I
believe it's the same in this one cuz
the guy known as the Grand Master who is
basically trying to dominate the world
and he would like you do don't like you
do it for your Grand Master and he lives
in Kazakh which is sort of this place
that's designed after you know old
Soviet it kind of looks like this is a
fantasy Russia yeah precisely so so yeah
I mean traditionally Strada was a
side-scrolling action game that you know
you played this ninja character that
have the ability to climb walls to
grapple on platforms give this really
fast saber initially there was an arcade
game and NES game and you know it's
tried to run out a whole bunch of
different platforms and then back on the
PlayStation Capcom made the definitive
Strider 2 which is actually kind
this but it was 2d character sprites on
pretty backgrounds and it was a
side-scrolling game okay so they did the
original strider never see like a
homeroom no it did it was a missus NES
then there was a stripe there was a
different strategy that was made not by
Capcom because how come isn't actually
own the rights to Strider it belongs to
I believe a company that owns rights
different manga series so every time
Capcom wasn't a canoe Strider game they
have this man who goes yeah yeah I know
a lot of people really love myself
included or really love me just like the
speed and momentum of this game feels
good it feels just to run around and cut
dudes up as you're seeing like I
imagined the original Strider games to
were probably based a lot on just like
high speed 2d platforming yeah it's like
that that's fine it definitely seemed
pretty quick but if you go back into the
old strata now especially in the home
consoles it if you played like this
they're like fast-paced you know modern
action platformer it just feels really
slow by comparison
everything is very deliberate and
drawn-out this is so much faster and one
of the interesting things that I'm
really looking forward to is the fact
that this game has that sort of you know
free roaming exploration aspect to it
like you find a you know Castlevania or
a Metroid I know we're folks we're
trying real hard not to use the word
Metroidvania right now I've never even
heard of it I don't even know what it is
I don't know why people keep saying it
yeah so that's a first for the series
where basically you have a gigantic map
you have a path and you have objectives
that you have to follow but you also
have the ability to explore and then
you'll find power-ups and you upgrades
to weapons and your health and one of
the cool things about that mixing with
Strider as a character as you can see he
has the ability to sort of climb up
walls and go through ceiling or you know
around ceilings and surprise and
surprise people yeah so that makes the
exploration thing pretty straightforward
there are a lot of locks in place you
know where a door will require secret
weapons yeah and something else we're
gonna see here in just a second is a
cipher upgrades for Striders weapon like
I'm about to get the slight upgrade
pretty soon like is that also something
a carryover from older cheri games like
power
no no the upgrade system is and but that
thing I that's that's fitting in with
via what did you call it mention the
castle Roy I believe is is the time yes
yeah
Castlevania wait a minute no that's the
actual name of the game Parros powers
yeah so you also spreader also has what
are known as options which is kind of a
turn these and universally human why not
you know the little pods that sort of
float around your character and those
come with different abilities that you
can upgrade as well although we won't
get into those yeah yeah this is coming
from double helix is developing this
right mm-hmm double helix the who
recently released the well receives a
killer instinct reboot as well yes and
working in the reboot Minds recently
yeah alright so yeah here we go here's
the the slide of bread that I'm talking
about and then we'll use this as Peter
was saying to sort of backtrack and open
up some new areas of the game to rate
the future and so W looks is developing
this for Capcom for the holiday the Xbox
360 in charge on ps3 ps4 which is the
version we're playing right now yeah
it's gonna be available PSN XBLA yes so
PC and then so both the current last gen
however you want to call Xbox one
ps4 ps3 and xbox you're sitting over
there okay well you know why no it's
good I'm oscillating also you know what
we're gonna hop down here and not yeah I
can totally open those things I get the
charge shot yeah but you know having
played the old games I've really enjoyed
the committee hours so I spent playing
this the other day the controls feel
incredible there's really my only
complaint is from the get-go you don't
have any means of defense yeah that was
something else a lot of Africa did you
have any sort of defensive capabilities
in the old against cuz that's something
I've seen people comment a lot of Joan
yeah you don't have any way to sort of
defend yourself besides like getting out
of the way or jumping over stuff yeah
because there are some scenes here in
this game when you have six people
requiring like you know a spread shot
yeah and it would be nice to be able to
you know slash away those projectiles
but you know it's potential that you
know throughout the game you'll acquire
some sort of defense yeah when I when I
played I played an area similar to this
at the most recent Tokyo Game Show and
they had the reflect cipher available to
you very early on it was one of the
first things you got pretty much around
the same time that you got the slight
attack and it definitely helps and it's
really it feels really good to like
specially against the shotgun guys is
that both I'll come out in a spread if
you just reflect it right when they
first shoot you get to shoot all those
pellets back at them and just wipe them
out yeah it's like you think you're so
smart
there are so you do get the charge
ability where you can sort of charge up
a powerful swipe of your blade and in
the right spirit
and mix it with a slide and actually
take out those groups of enemies that we
were describing that were hard to evade
you can take them out pretty simply but
it's it's kind of up to you to to suffer
a bit to find the right mix of moves
like a serious moves at all it'll make
it easier than just didn't hit something
else I think people maybe recognize
about oldish arrogance that you also had
delightful animal companions get like a
bird and a robotics wolf yeah if I
remember correctly yeah and you get the
you get the Eagle here I don't have not
seen them off a little later on I don't
think not sure if we'll get the shoulder
not but you do get me the eagle powerup
he helps you get from one area to
another and he can also be used as a
sort of projectile attack yeah that's
the charge up as we use them and they're
like little launch pads in the game sort
of like an elevator
yeah maybe a metro right or it's an
equal basis all right well I'm gonna try
to power through the rest of the fight
and next was it's coming out you know
this is I don't think they have a
definite like day and date release date
yet but they've so far I think they're
just saying early 2014-15 bones $14.99
valve
yeah this game was announced not too
long ago yeah and a real fast turnaround
yeah so I don't know 15 bucks
well I mean the original original
Striders you could power through pretty
quickly though yeah but this is
different right this is a exploration
yeah hypothetically you should have a
lot of stuff to explore because that's
what makes this game sound great but if
it's only like you know three hours 20
minutes
it's not but I'm optimistic because it's
really it really is fun to play and that
mean really that's but even you know the
next rider to on the PlayStation that
game he had infinite continues and you
could power through that so fast but I
still really like that really how does
how would like me is it difficult
- you spent time with Rosalyn
easier harder like you just mentioned
that started to did have infinite
continued so I imagine that did oh these
things up quite a bit yeah you would die
quite off I mean me and half of that you
know it's you got used to dying right
this game definitely like I've died a
few times like please playing it
casually yeah it definitely a man's more
of you so I say this is a little bit
harder than Strider Tula's it's likely
because the run can infinite continues
okay thanks for sitting down with me
sharing some of your insights into the
world of Strider I hope it helps hope
you guys love checking out the game I'm
axel me this is Peter Brown stay tuned
to the site for ongoing Strider coverage